OK.
So, coming nearer the
end of the course,
this lecture will be a mixture
of the linear algebra that
comes with a change of basis.
And a change of basis from
one basis to another basis
is something you really
do in applications.
And, I would like to talk
about those applications.
I got a little bit
involved with compression.
Compressing a signal,
compressing an image.
And that's exactly
change-of-basis.
And then, the main
theme in this chapter
is th- the connection between
a linear transformation, which
doesn't have to
have coordinates,
and the matrix that tells
us that transformation
with respect to coordinates.
So the matrix is the
coordinate-based description
of the linear transformation.
Let me start out with
the nice part, which
is just to tell you something
about image compression.
Those of you -- well,
everybody's going to meet
compression, because you know
that the amount of data that
we're getting --
well, these lectures
are compressed.
So that, actually, probably
you see my motion as
jerky?
Shall I use that word?
Have you looked on the web?
I should like to
find a better word.
Compressed, let's say.
So the complete signal is, of
course, in those video cameras,
and in the videotape,
but that goes
to the bottom of building
nine, and out of that
comes a jumpy motion because
it uses a standard system
for compressing images.
And, you'll notice that the
stuff that sits on the board
comes very clearly, but
it's my motion that needs
a whole lot of bits, right?
So, and if I were to run up
and back up there and back,
that would need too
many bits, and I'd
be compressed even more.
So, what does compression mean?
Let me just think
of a still image.
And of course, satellites,
and computations
of the climate,
computations of combustion,
the computers and
sensors of all kinds
are just giving us
overwhelming amounts of data.
The Web is, too.
Now, some compression
can be done with no loss.
Lossless compression is possible
just using, sort of, the fact
that there are redundancies.
But I'm talking here
about lossy compression.
So I'm talking about
-- here's an image.
And what does an
image consist of?
It consists of a lot of
little pixels, right?
Maybe five hundred and twelve
by five hundred and twelve.
Two to the ninth by two
to the ninth pixels,
and so this is pixel number
one, one, so that's a pixel.
And if we're in black and
white, the typical pixel
would tell us a gray-scale,
from zero to two fifty five.
So a pixel is usually a
value of one of the xi,
so this would be the
i-th pixel, is --
it's usually a real
number on a scale
from zero to two fifty five.
In other words, two to
the eighth possibilities.
So usually, that's the standard,
so that's eight -- eight bits.
But then we have
that for every pixel,
so we have five hundred
and twelve squared pixels,
we're really operating x is a
vector in R^n, but what is n?
n is five hundred
and twelve squared.
That's our problem, right there.
A pixel is a vector
that gives us
the information about the image.
I'm sorry.
The image that comes through is
a vector of that length that --
that's the information that
we have about the image,
if it's a color image, we would
have three times that length,
because we'd need three
coordinates to get color.
So it would be three times five
hundred and twelve squared.
It's an enormous
amount of information,
and we couldn't send out
the image for these lectures
without compressing it.
It would overload the system.
So it has to be compressed.
The standard compression,
and still used with lectures
is, called JPEG.
I think that stands for Joint
Photographic Experts Group.
They established a
system of compression.
And I just want to tell
you what it's about.
It's a change-of-basis.
What basis do we have?
The current basis
we have is, you
could say, the standard basis
is, every pixel, give a value.
So that's like we have a
vector x which is five hundred
and twelve squared long
and, in the i-th position,
we get a number like one
twenty one or something.
The pixel next to it might
be one twenty four, maybe
where my tie begins to enter,
so if it was mostly blue shirt,
this would be a slight
difference in shading,
but pretty close, then the tie
would be a different color,
so we might have
quite a few pixels
for the blue shirt,
and a whole lot
more for the blackboard,
that are very close.
And that's what are
very correlated.
And that's what gives us the
possibility of compression.
For example, before
the lecture starts,
if we had a blank blackboard,
then there's an image,
but it would make no
sense to take that image
and tell you what it
is pixel by pixel.
I mean, there's a case in
which all pixel values,
all gray levels are the same --
or practically the same,
depending on the erasing
of the board, but
extremely close --
and, so that's an image where
the standard basis is lousy.
That's the basic fact, that
the standard basis which gives
the value of every pixel
makes no use of the fact that
we're getting a whole lot of
pixels whose gray levels --
the neighboring pixels tend
to have the same gray level
as their neighbors.
So how do we take
advantage of that fact?
Well, one basis
vector that would
be extremely nice to
include in the basis
would be a vector of all ones.
That's not in our
standard basis,
so let me just write again,
the standard basis is our one,
and all the rest zeroes, zero,
one, and all the rest, zeroes,
everybody knows what
these standard basis is.
Now, any other basis
for R -- so this is --
for this very
high-dimensional space --
now I'm going to speak
about a better basis.
Better basis -- and
let me just emphasize,
one vector that would be
extremely nice to have in that
basis is the vector of all ones.
Why is that?
Let me just say again, because
that vector of all ones,
by itself, one vector is
able to completely give
the information
on a solid image.
Of course, our image
won't be solid,
it will have a mix
of solid and signal.
So having that one
vector in the basis
is going to save us a whole lot.
Now, the question is, what other
vectors should be in the basis?
The extreme vector
in the basis might
be a vector of one minus one,
one minus one, one minus one.
That would be a
vector that shows --
I mean, that's like a
checkerboard vector, right?
That's a vector that
would, if the image was
like a huge checkerboard
of plus, minus,
plus, minus, plus,
minus, that vector
would carry the whole signal.
But much more common
would be maybe
to have half the image, darker
and the other half lighter.
So another vector that might
be quite useful in here
would be half ones
and half minus ones.
I'm just trying to get across
the idea of that a basis could
be where, that
first of all, we've
got the bases at our disposal.
Like, we're free to choose that.
And it's a billion-dollar
decision what we choose.
So, and TV people
would rather pre-
would prefer one basis based on
the way the signal is scanned,
and movie people
would prefer another,
I mean, there's giant
politics in this question that
really reduces to a
linear algebra problem,
what basis to choose.
I'll just mention the best
known basis, which JPEG uses, --
let me put that here --
is the Fourier basis.
So when you use the Fourier
basis, that includes --
this is the constant vector, the
D C vector if we're electrical
engineers, the l- vector of all
ones, so it would include one,
one, one, one.
Often eight by eight
is a good choice.
Eight by eight is a good choice.
So, what do I mean by
this eight by eight?
I mean that the big signal,
which is five twelve by five
twelve, gets broken down, and
JPEG does this, into eight
by eight blocks.
And we -- sort of, this is
too much to deal with at once.
So what JPEG does is take
this eight by eight block,
which is sixty four
coefficients, sixty four,
pixels, and changes
the basis on that
piece.
And then, now, let's see, I was
going to write down Fourier,
so you remember Fourier as this
vector of all ones, and then,
the vector -- oh,
well, actually,
I gave a lecture earlier
about the Fourier matrix,
this matrix whose columns are
powers of a complex number w.
I won't repeat that,
because I don't
want to go into the details
of the Fourier basis,
just to tell you how
compression works.
So what happens in JPEG?
What happens to the video, to
each image, of these lectures?
It gets broken into
eight by eight blocks.
OK.
Within each block, we have
sixty four coefficients,
sixty four basis vectors,
sixty four pixels,
and we change basis in
sixty four dimensional space
using these Fourier vectors.
Just note, that was
a lossless step.
Let me emphasize.
In comes the signal x.
We change basis.
This is the basis change.
Change basis.
Choose a better basis.
So it produces,
the coefficients c.
So sixty four pixels come
in, sixty four coefficients
come out.
Now comes the compression.
Now come -- this was lossless.
It's just -- we know that R --
R sixty four has plenty of
bases, and we've chosen one.
Now, in that basis, we write
the signal in that basis,
and that's what my lecture
-- that's the math part
of my lecture.
Now here's the application part.
The next part is going to
be the compression step.
And that's lossy.
We're going to lose information.
And what will actually
happen at that step?
Well, one thing we could
do is just throw away
the small coefficients.
So that's called thresholding,
we set some threshold.
Every coefficient, every
basis vector that's
not in there more than
the threshold value,
and we set them threshold
so that our eye can't
see the difference, or can
hardly see the difference,
whether we throw away that
little bit of that basis vector
or keep it.
So this compression step
produces a compressed set of
I'll just keep going
here. coefficients.
So it keeps going,
this compression step
produces some coefficient c hat.
And with many zeroes.
So that's where the
compression came.
Probably, there is enough of
this vector of all ones --
we very seldom throw that away.
Usually, its coefficient
will be large.
But the coefficient of
something like this,
that quickly alternative
vector, there's
probably very little of
that in any smooth signal.
That's high-frequency -- this is
low-frequency, zero frequency.
This stuff is the highest
frequency we could have,
and if the noise, the jitter is
producing that sort of output,
but a smooth lecture
like this one
is, has very little of
that highest frequency,
very little noise
in this lecture.
OK, so we throw away
whatever there is,
and we're left with
just a few coefficients,
and then we reconstruct a
signal using those coefficients.
We take those coefficients,
times their basis vectors,
but this sum doesn't have
sixty four terms any more.
Probably, it has about
two or three terms.
So that would --
say it has three terms.
From sixty four down
to three, that's
compression of
twenty one to one.
That's the kind of compression
you're looking for.
And everybody is looking for
that sort of compression.
Let's see, I guess
I met the problem
with the FBI and fingerprints.
So there's a whole
lot of still images.
You know, with your thumb,
you make these inky marks
which go somewhere.
it used to go to Washington
and get stored in a big file.
So Washington had a file of
thirty million murderers,
cheaters on quizzes,
other stuff,
and actually, there was no
way to retrieve them in time.
So suppose you're at the
police station, they say, OK,
this person may have done
this, check with Washington,
have they got -- are his or
her fingerprints on file?
Well, Washington won't know
the answer within a week
if it's got filing cabinets
full of fingerprints.
So of course, the natural
step is digitizing.
So all fingerprints
are now digitized,
so now it's at least electronic,
but still there's too much
information in each one.
I mean, you can't search
through that many, fingerprints
if the digital image is five
twelve squared by five twelve
squared, if it's
that many pixels.
So you get compressed.
So the FBI had to decide what
basis to choose for compression
of fingerprints.
And then they built a big new
facility in West Virginia,
and that's where
fingerprints now are sent.
So I think, if you get
your fingerprints done now
at the police station, if it's
an up-to-date police station,
it happens digitally, and
the signal is sent digitally,
and then in West Virginia,
it's compressed and indexed.
And then, if they
want to find you,
they can do it within minutes
instead of within a week.
OK.
So this compression comes
up for signals, for images,
for video -- which is,
like these lectures --
there's another aspect.
You could treat the video as one
still image after another one,
and compress each one, and
then run them and make a video.
But that misses --
well, you can see why
that's not optimal.
In a video thing, you
have a sequence of images,
so video is really a sequence
of images but what about one
image to the next image?
They're extremely correlated.
I mean that I'm getting an
image every split-second,
and also, I'm moving slightly.
That's what's producing the,
jumpy motion on the video.
But I'm not, like, you know --
each image in the sequence is
pretty close to the one before.
So you have to use, like,
prediction and correction.
I mean, the image of me one
instant -- one time-step later,
you would assume
would be the same,
and then plus a
small correction.
And you would only code and
digitize the correction,
and compress the correction.
So a sequence of images
that's highly correlated
and the problem in
compression is always
to use this
correlation, this fact
that, in time, or
in space, things
don't change instantly, they're
very often smooth changes,
and, you can predict one
value from the previous value.
OK.
So those are applications
which are pure linear algebra.
I could, well, maybe you'll
allow me to tell you,
and the book describes,
the new basis that's
the competition for Fourier.
So the competition for
Fourier is called wavelets,
and I can describe what
that basis is like,
say, in the eight by eight case.
So the eight by
eight wavelet basis
is the vector of all
ones, eight ones, then
the vector of four ones
and four minus ones,
then the vector of two
ones, and two minus ones,
and four zeroes.
And also the vector
of four zeroes
and two ones and two minus ones.
So now I'm up to four, and
I need four more, right?
For R^8?
The next basis vector will be
one minus one and six zeroes,
and then three more like
that, with the one minus one
there, and there, and there.
So those are eight vectors
in eight-dimensional space,
those are called wavelets,
and it's a very simple wavelet
choice, it's a
more sophisticated
choice.
This is a little jumpy, to
jump between one and minus one.
And, actually, you
can see, now, suppose
you compare the wavelet basis
with the Fourier basis above.
How could I write this guy,
which is in the Fourier basis,
it's an eight --
it's a vector in R^8.
How would I write
that as a combination
of the wavelet basis?
Have I told you enough about the
wavelet basis that you can see,
how does this very fast guy --
what combination of the wavelet
basis is that very fast guy?
It would be this one --
it would be the sum
of these four, right?
That very fast guy will
be that one minus one,
and the next one, and the
next one, and the next one.
So this is the sum of
those last four wavelets.
This one, we've kept, and so on.
So, each -- well, every --
well, that's what a basis does.
Every vector in R^8 is
some combination of those,
and for the linear algebra --
so the linear algebra is this
step, find the coefficient.
That's the step we want to take.
What if I give you the basis,
like this wavelet basis,
and I give you the pixel -- so
here are the pixel values, P1,
P2, down to P8 --
what's the job?
What's the linear algebra here?
So these are the values, this
is in the standard basis, right?
Those are just the values
at eight successive points.
I guess I'm dropping down to
one dimension, instead of eight
by eight, I'm just going
to take eight pixel values
along that first top row.
So what do I want to do?
In standard basis, here
are the pixel values.
I want to write that as a
combination of c1 times this
guy, plus c2 times
this guy, plus c3,
these are the coefficients,
plus c4 times this one --
do you see what I'm doing?
I want to write this vector P
as a combination of c1 times
the first wavelet plus c8
times the eighth wavelet.
That's the transform step.
That's the lossless step.
That's the step from P --
oh, I'm calling it P here,
and I called it x
there, so let me --
at the risk of moving, and
therefore making this jumpy --
suppose the signal I'm now
calling P, that a pixel values,
and I'm looking for
the coefficients.
OK, tell me how to do it.
If I give you eight
basis vectors,
and I give you the input signal,
and I ask for the coefficients,
what do I do?
What's the step?
I'm trying to solve this, I want
to know the eight coefficients,
so I'm changing from the
standard basis, which is just
the eight gray-scale values
to the wavelet basis, where
the same vector is
represented by eight numbers.
It's got to take eight numbers
to tell you a vector in R^8,
and those eight numbers are
the coefficients of the basis.
Look, we've done
this thing before.
There is the equation
in vector notation,
we want to see it as a matrix.
This is a combination of
columns of the wavelet matrix,
right?
This is P equals
c1, c2, down to c8,
and these guys are the columns.
I mean, this is the step
that we're constantly
taking in this course,
the first basis vector
goes in the first column,
the second basis vector
goes in the second
column, and so on,
the eight columns of
this wavelet matrix
are the eight basis vectors.
This is a wavelet matrix W.
So, the step to change basis
-- so now I'm finally coming
to this change-of-basis, so
the change of basis that,
let me stay with this
board, but -- well,
let me just go above it, here.
So the standard basis, we know,
the wavelet basis we have here,
and the transform is
simply, solve the equations,
P=W C. So the coefficients
are W inverse P. Right.
This shows a critical point.
A good basis has a
nice, fast, inverse.
So good basis means what?
So this is like the
billion-dollar competition,
Eh? and it's not over yet.
People are going to come up
with better bases than these.
So a good basis will be, first
good thing would be fast.
I have to be able to multiply
by W fast, and multiply by W --
by its inverse fast.
That's -- if a basis doesn't
allow you to do that fast,
then it's going to take so much
time that you can't afford it.
So these bases --
the Fourier basis,
everybody said, OK, I
know how to deal quickly
with the Fourier basis,
because we have something called
the Fast Fourier Transform.
So there's a FFT that came
in my earlier lecture,
and comes in the last
chapter of the book,
so change-of-basis is done
-- if, for the Fourier basis,
it's done fast by the FFT
and there's a fast wavelet
transform.
I can change, for
this wavelet example,
this matrix is easy to invert.
It's just somebody
had a smart idea
in choosing that wavelet
basis and inverting it,
it has a nice inverse.
Actually, you can see why
Do you see any property of
these eight basis vectors?
Well, I've only
written five of them,
but if you see that
property for those five,
you'll see it for the three
remaining.
Well, if I give you
those eight vectors
and ask, what's a nice property?
Well, you would say, first,
they're all ones and minus ones
and zeroes.
So every multiplication is very
fast using -- just in binary.
But what's the other great
property of those vectors?
Anybody see it?
So, of course, when I
think about a basis,
one nice property --
I don't have to have it, but
I'm happy if it's there --
is that they're orthogonal.
If the basis vectors
are orthogonal,
then I'm in good shape.
And these are... do you see?
Take the dot product
of that with that,
you get four plus ones and
four minus ones, you get zero.
Take the dot product
of that with that.
You get two plus ones
and two minus ones.
Or the dot product
of that with that.
Two plus ones and
two minus ones.
You can easily check that
that's an orthogonal basis.
It's not orthonormal.
To fix it up, I should
divide by the length,
to make them unit vectors.
Let's suppose I do that.
So somewhere in here, I've
got to account for the fact
that this has length
square root of eight, that
has length square
root of four, that
has length square root of two.
But that's just a constant
factor that's easy to --
so suppose we've done that.
Then, tell me what's W inverse?
That's what chapter four,
section four point four
was about.
If we have orthonormal
columns then
the inverse is the
same as the transpose.
So if we have a fast way to
multiply by W, which we do,
the inverse is going
to look just the same,
and we'll have a fast way to do
W inverse.
So that's the wavelet basis
passes this requirement
for fast.
We can use it fast.
But there's a second
requirement, is it any good?
Because the the
very fastest thing
we could do is not to
change basis at all.
Right?
The fastest thing would be, OK,
stay with the standard basis,
stay with eight pixel values.
But that was poor from
compression point of view,
right?
Those eight pixel values, if I
just took those eight numbers,
I can't throw some
of those away.
If I throw away
ninety percent --
if I compress ten to
one, and throw away
ninety percent of
my pixel values,
well, my picture's
just gone dark.
Whereas, the basis
that was good,
the wavelet basis or
the Fourier basis,
if I throw away c5, c6, c7,
and c8, all I'm throwing away
is little blips that
are probably there
in very small amounts.
So the second property that
we need is good compression.
So first, it has to be fast, and
secondly, a few basis vectors
should come close to the signal.
So a few is enough.
Can I write it that way?
A few basis vectors are enough
to reproduce the image just
exactly as on a video
of these 18.06 lectures.
Uh, I don't know what the
compression rate is, I'll ask,
David, who does the
compression -- and, by the way,
I'll try to get the lectures,
that are relevant for the quiz
up onto the Web in time.
So I'll send them
a message today.
So, he's using the Fourier
basis because the JPEG --
so JPEG two thousand, which will
be the next standard for image
compression, will
include wavelets.
So, I mean, you're actually
getting a kind of up-to-date,
picture of where this big world
of signal and image processing
is.
That Fourier is
what everybody knew,
and what people
automatically used,
and the new one is
wavelets, where this is
the simplest set of wavelets.
And this isn't the one that
the FBI uses, by the way,
the FBI uses a smoother
wavelet, instead
of jumping from one to minus
one, it's a smooth, Cutoff.
and, that's what we'll be
in in JPEG two thousand.
OK, so that's that application.
Now, let me come to the
math, the linear algebra
part of the lecture.
Well, we've actually
seen a change-of-basis.
So let -- let me just review
that eh-eh change-of-basis
idea, and then the i- and then
the transformation to a matrix.
OK.
So this, I hope you see
that these applications are
really big.
Now, I have to talk a little
about change-of-basis,
and a little about that.
The matrix.
OK.
So change-of-basis.
Basically, forgive
that put, OK, I have,
I have my vector in
one basis, and I want
to change to a different one.
Actually, you saw it
for the wavelet case.
So I need the --
let the matrix W,
and the columns of W
be the new basis vectors.
Then the change-of-basis
involves, just
as it did there, W inverse.
So we have the vector,
say, x, in the old basis,
and that converts to a vector,
let's say, c, in the new basis,
and the relation is exactly what
we had there, that x is W c.
That's the step we have to take.
There's a matrix W that
gives us a change-of-basis.
OK.
What I want to do is think about
transformations on matrices.
So here's the question
to complete this lecture.
Suppose I have a linear
transformation T.
So we would think of it as an
eight -- as a n by n matrix.
And it's computed with
respect to a certain basis.
So T -- no, I'm sorry.
I've got the
transformation T, period.
That's taking
eight-dimensional space
to eight-dimensional space.
Now, let's get
matrices in there.
OK.
So, with respect to a first
basis, say v1 up to v8,
it has a matrix A.
I'm just setting
up letters here.
With respect to a second basis,
say, I'll make it u1 up to --
or w1, since I've used (w)s,
w1 up to w8, it has a matrix B.
And my question is, what's
the connection between A
How is the matrix -- the
transformation T is settled.
and B?
We could say, it's a
rotation, for example.
So that would be
one transformation
of eight-dimensional space,
just spin it a little.
Or project it.
Or whatever linear
transformation we've got.
Now, we have to remember --
my first step is to remind you
how you create that matrix A.
Then my second step is, we would
use the same method to create
B, but because it came from
the same transformation,
there's got to be a
relation between A and B.
What's the relation
between A and B?
And let me jump to the
answer on that one.
That if I have the
same transformation,
and I'm compute on its matrix in
one basis, and then I computer
it in another basis, those
two matrices are similar.
So these two
matrices are similar.
Now, do you remember what
similar matrices meant?
Similar.
A is similar to -- the
two matrices are similar.
Similar.
And what do I mean by that?
I mean that I take the matrix
B, and I can compute it
from the matrix A using
some similarity, some matrix
M on one side, and M
inverse on the other.
And this M will be the
change-of-basis matrix.
This part of the lecture
is, admittedly, compressed.
What I wanted you to --
it's really the conclusion
that I want you to spot.
Now, I have to go back and
say, what does it mean for A
to be the matrix of
this transformation T.
So I have to remind
you what that meant,
that was in the last lecture.
Then this is the conclusion
that if I change to a different
basis, we now know -- see, if
I change to a different basis,
two things happen.
Every vector has
new coordinates.
There, the rule is this one,
between the old coordinates
and the new ones.
Every matrix changes, every
transformation has a new
matrix.
And the new matrix
is related this way,
the M could be
the same as the W.
The M there would be the W here.
OK.
So, can I, in the
remaining minutes,
recapture my lecture -- the
end of my lecture that was just
before Thanksgiving,
about the matrix?
OK.
What's the matrix?
And I'll just take one basis.
So now this part is going
to go onto this board here.
What is the matrix?
What is A?
OK.
Using a basis v1 up to v8.
Mm.
OK.
What's the point?
The point is, if I know
what the transformation does
to those eight basis vectors,
I know it completely.
I know T, I know
everything about T,
I know T completely from knowing
T of V -- what T does to v1,
what T does to v2,
what T does to v8.
Why is that?
It's because T is a
linear transformation.
So that if I know what
these outputs are --
so these are the
inputs v1 up to v8,
these are the outputs
from the transformation,
like everyone rotated,
everyone projected,
whatever transformation
I've done,
then why is it that
I know everything?
How does linearity work?
Why?
This is because every x is
some combination of these basis
vectors, right?
c1v1, c2v2, c8v8,
they were a basis.
That's the whole
point of a basis,
that every vector is a
combination of the basis
vectors in exactly one way.
And then, what is T of x?
The point is, I claim that
we know T of x completely
for every x, because every x
is a combination of those --
and now we use the linear
transformation part to say that
the output from x has to be c1
times the output from v1 plus
v2 times the output
from v2, and so on.
Up through c8 times
the output from v8.
So this is like just saying, OK.
We know everything
when we know what
T does to each basis vector.
OK.
So those are the
eight things we need.
Now -- but we need these
answers in this basis.
So this first output
is some combination
of the eight basis vectors.
So write T acting on the
first input -- in other words,
write the first output as
a combination of the basis
vectors, say a11 v1 +
a21 v2 and so on a81 v8.
Write T of v2 as some
combination a12 of v1,
a22 of v2 and so on.
I'm creating the matrix
A, column by column.
Those numbers go in
the first column,
these numbers go in the second
column, the matrix A that thi-
this -- this is our matrix that
represents T in this basis is
these numbers.
a11 down to a18, a21
down to a28, and so on.
OK.
That's the recipe.
In other words, if I give you
a transformation, and a basis.
So that's what I
have to give you.
The inputs are the
basis and to tell you
what the transformation
is.
And then, you tell me --
you compute T for
each basis, expand
that result in the
basis, and that gives you
the sixty four numbers
that go into the matrix A.
Let me suppose -- let's close
with the best example of all.
Suppose v1 to v8, this
basis, is the eigenvectors.
Suppose we have an eigenvector
basis so that T(vi)
is in the same direction of vi.
Now, my question is, what is A?
Can you carry through the steps?
Let's do them together, because
we can do it in one minute.
So, we've chosen
this perfect basis.
And, actually, with
signal image processing,
they might look for
the eigenvectors.
But that would take
more calculation
time that just saying, OK,
we'll use the wavelet basis.
Or, OK, we'll use
the Fourier basis.
But the very best basis
is the eigenvector basis.
OK, what's the matrix?
So, what's the first
column of the matrix?
How do I get the first column?
I take the first
basis vector v1.
I opt -- I look to see, what
does the transformation do
to it?
The output is lambda one v1.
I express that output as a
combination so the first input
is v1.
Its output is lambda one v1.
Now write lambda one v1 as
a combination of the basis
vectors, well,
it's already done.
It's just lambda one times
the first basis vector
and zero times the others.
So this first column will
have lambda one and zeroes.
OK.
Second input is v2.
Output is lambda two v2.
OK, write that output as
a combination of the (v)s.
It's already done.
It's just lambda two
times the second v.
So we need, in
the second column,
we have lambda two
times the second v.
Well, you see what's
coming, that in that basis,
in the eigenvector basis,
the matrix is diagonal.
So that's the
perfect basis, that's
the basis we'd love to
have for image processing,
but to find the eigenvectors
of our pixel matrix
would be too expensive.
So we do something
cheaper and close,
which is to choose a
good basis like wavelets.
OK, thanks.
So I'll -- quiz review
on Wednesday, all day.
Thanks.